Jonathan Wasserman he NBA draft writer
for bleacher report kind enough to join
us we're getting ready for wingspan
night tomorrow night Jonathan is that
going to be the go-to expression
tomorrow night yeah you can have a drink
for every time you hear the word
wingspan and you're gonna get drunk
you're gonna hear it all the time
particularly with mo Bamba I mean they
should really cut it off after three
wingspans but that's pretty much the
word you're going to hear a time
particularly with guys like Baba and
Janet Jackson's got the 75 wingspan it
and stop there all right trade rumors
let's start there
what are you here trade rumors Wow I
mean everyone's trying to move down I
think that's gonna be a problem because
everybody wants to move down I think
guys think that you get the same guy at
number seven they can at number three
the Hoffs at number three are going to
be the first team looking to move down I
know the Mavericks are taking calls the
Knicks are gonna want to try and move up
but they don't have anything that moves
up but there's gonna be a lot of phone
calls and conversation really tough to
say what's actually going to go down but
the phones are gonna be very busy
what about Cleveland in what is
Cleveland's game plan not knowing what
LeBrons future is going to be yeah I
think they're gonna stick at number
eight and they're gonna take the best
player available they need they need
some young talent and I don't know how
confident they are that LeBron is coming
back and if he's not coming back then
they definitely need to stick and draft
a young player that they can develop and
from what I hear LeBron James has his
opinion has nothing to do with what
they're going to do at number eight I
think they just they got to go with
their guts find the best player
available whether he could help now or
whether you're he helps two or three
years down the road most polarizing
players who very young no doubt about it
I just got a text from a executive who
now believes he's dropping out of the
top ten and this is a guy who led the
country in scoring and assists you know
no one's ever done that before some
people think he is a Steph Curry light
some people think he is a backup point
guard like Tyus Jones it's just you know
there's no consensus on who Trey Young
is and what he's gonna be but but
Jonathan how is he dropping now what
what has happened
I think a lot of guys are also rising
and naturally as guys rise somebody has
to drop and I think there are teams who
just they see him in person they realize
man is small he's not a great athlete he
had an unbelievable green light in
college that he's not going to have at
the NBA level and if you know if you
don't think he's going to be a star
caliber starting point guard in the NBA
and you don't take him top ten yeah you
don't you don't want to take the chances
of grabbing a point guard and ends up
being your backup the top ten pick and
this is just a very strong field in
general and a lot of guys are
interviewing very well really high
character smart guys who I think are
helping themselves during this pre-draft
process and then meantime somebody's got
to fall and a bunch of teams do have
point guards and I think unfortunately
that means Trey young slips maybe to the
Clippers at 12 or 13 I also look at this
and I think we overthink these drafts
because we'll take potential
overproduction any day III can look at
Marvin Bagley and say he did everything
you wanted at Duke where you know 21 a
game ACC Player of the Year
but Michael Porter Jr who played what 50
minutes in his college career it feels
like it's more intriguing than Marvin
Bagley or DeAndre Aiden right yeah I
mean people want scores and Porter is a
scorer having said that I also just got
a message saying that Porter is on the
decline he's falling and mainly because
of his medical reports and like he said
played 53 minutes this season and nobody
wants a guy with back trouble this early
in his career so now Porter is obviously
interesting because he's a 611 face-up
scorer you know kinda reminds guys of
Brandon Ingram and Kevin Durant which
those are mismatches we can feed the
ball two and a half court and feature
but you also don't want to take a chance
with it with the injury risk and also
the fact that there are so many other
solid options least riskiest player is
Luca da judge who is ironically didn't
even play this country and dodge is
we've seen him I know he's overseas but
he's the most proven player in this
draft we've already seen him at
Eurobasket last year he beat up on
porzingis and last year he beat up on
Spain and the Gasol and her name Gomez
Brothers and Ricky Rubio it was just the
youngest player to ever win Euroleague
MVP I mean usually 18 19 year olds are
praised if they get minutes
in your league and he was the best
player if nobody playing against former
first-round picks and seasoned pros in
Europe there's no question six eight
he's 220 an excellent passer excellent
shooter one of the top scorers in
Euroleague there's just nothing to
really question about him and really
really competitive kid talking to
Jonathan Wasserman bleacher report their
lead NBA draft writer who's the sneaky
guy who's the guy who when we we look
back he might be Donovan Mitchell or
draymond Green that kind of player ah
man there's well in different tiers of
the draft we'll start at the top with
Wendell Carter jr. who played for Duke
and he was overshadowed by Bagley who
you know had a lot more touches and was
a 2010 guy Carter didn't see the ball as
much but this game may be better suited
for the NBA really strung around the
basket a much better shooter than you
had the freedom to show at Duke so I
think he's got the chance to be a top
five player in this draft and I think if
you moved down the board dante's even
Chenzhou from Villanova was the kid who
dropped 31 in the national title game
you never really heard the word NBA tied
to his name until that night then he
shows up at the combine was one of the
best players on the floor during
five-on-five really humble kid when the
top athletes in the draft does a little
bit of everything passes defends shoots
it well I think even Chandler
particularly if he lands in a area where
he could play to his strengths he's
going to be a very very good I wouldn't
say draymond Green type of player but
that type of
do-it-all jack-of-all-trades guy who's
going to impact games without needing
his number calls what about Grayson
Ellen yeah another polarizing guy and I
think Allen has actually helped himself
and interviews obviously he had you know
the the tripping incidents and people
questioned his maturity in his character
but you know I truly believe and I think
others do too it was he had some mental
lapses and I think he's gotten past him
and he does have NBA caliber skills he's
media over eighty threes and three
consecutive seasons teams all neat shot
makers put him around the around the arc
let him run off screens let him spot up
he's got a chance again to make an
impact if he does land you know on a
good team where all he has to do is
catch and shoot I think he's got a
chance to go possibly somewhere in
late 20s I got them right now going to
the Boston Celtics player most likely to
be the biggest bust out of this group is
okay this is gonna be a tough answer but
the number one pick him address DeAndre
and I don't mean bust by he's gonna be
as a league like Anthony said in a
couple years but when you're the number
one pick in the draft I think your
expectation is to be an all-star every
year and to change the culture and
direction of your franchise Aidan's
gonna go number one and I think he's
going to wind up being a stats over
Williams type of guy where the team
continues to stink yeah he puts up big
numbers and the production doesn't
really match the value so I think
looking back after a few years the sun's
may regret taking a to number one but we
also look at the new NBA Jonathan and it
feels like why are you know you're
taking a big man number one and in
today's NBA does that make sense
taking a big man number one I mean only
if you think that guy is going to be one
of the best players in the league in a
couple years and one of the reasons why
on my big board Aidan is not number one
he's actually number three it's because
if you're gonna take a big guy number
one he better be good at defense and
Aidan's biggest weakness is defense I
mean if he's a guy who can't protect the
rim at center then that's a problem for
me and and and I guess the Phoenix Suns
just love his offensive upside you know
he kind of reminds me of a DeMarcus
Cousins it's going to give you those big
numbers twenty ten every night but
Cousins is teams have been better almost
when he has been off the floor and so I
guess they see a very safe play with
eighties 7 1 to 57 5 wingspan powerful
athletic skilled but with the way the
NBA is going with five guys around the
perimeter you know he doesn't quite fit
the mold of a franchise number one pick
Jonathan thank you great stuff have fun
tomorrow night we appreciate your time
and so Jonathan Wasserman bleacher
report their lead NBA draft writer for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on directiy
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]